-Cardi and I are about to face
off in a game of "Box of Lies."
Now, here's how it works.
Upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects
neither of us have seen before.
You remove the object
from the box,
you show it
to our great audience,
then you look at your opponent
and tell them
what's in your box.
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
[ Dramatically ] Cardi, why
don't you pick the first box?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Dramatically ]
Are you ready to play a game?
Are you ready?
[ Normal voice ]
Uh, choose the first box.
Audience, want to help her out?
-Four!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Four is my lucky number.
-Four!
-Really? Okay. All right.
-11 and 4.
-All right. Do you want me
to help get this?
I don't want you
to keep getting up.
But this is all
part of the game.
-Yeah, cause you're trying
to cheat and stuff here.
-I'm not cheating!
Oh, I can tell.
I can tell it's very light.
I can tell it's very --
by the way you carried it over.
-[ Chuckles ] Hmm.
-[ Laughs ]
-Aah! Wait!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Mm-hmm. Uh-huh.
[ Audience gasps ]
Okay. All right.
[ Audience laughs ]
The audience is very --
The audience is confusing me now
because they just had like
10 different reactions.
One was [Gasps].
Then it was, "Aww!"
And then it was like, "Huh?"
And then they laughed.
-Let me touch it.
[ Laughter ]
-What is that again?
[ Laughs ]
-I'm touching it.
-Okay, you're touching it
right now.
-It's fluffy.
-Mm-hmm.
-Or is it?
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. That's not --
"It's fluffy, or is it?"
Uh-huh.
What is in your box?
-Not a penis.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Hey! Hey!
He really wants to quit.
-No!
-What a sore loser.
-Oh, I am so --
I am ready to win.
All right, so, what is it?
What is it?
Tell me what it is.
-I don't know what it is.
-All right.
You're gonna have to
make up something because
I have to guess if you're lying
or telling the truth.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what it is.
-I can wait.
You can think of a name for it.
And I can tell you if I think --
You have to know what it is.
-Uh, pussy balls.
[ Laughter ]
Are they pussy balls or not?
Now, pussy balls...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
I am going to say -- I'm saying
you tell the truth.
Let me see.
[ Laughter ]
Hey!
♪♪
I'll take --
-Can you please
hold my pussy balls?
-Nah, I knew
that was gonna happen.
Okay, good, all right.
I have your --
Here we go.
What number, guys?
-Three!
-All right. Thank you.
One person.
One person is on my side.
Unbelievable.
My sister yelled out, "Three."
Yeah. Perfect.
Here we go. Let me get this.
[ Grunting loudly ]
Ungghhh! So heavy!
I'm playing jump rope
in your head right now.
Oh, yeah.
Yep, yep, yep, yep,
yep, yep, yep!
[ Humming ]
♪♪
Let me talk to you a second.
I just want to tell you
something between us.
What I have here in my box
is a stuffed animal.
[ Laughter ]
It's got a Freddy Krueger
claw on it.
Hat.
It's a wrinkly dog.
It's a wrinkly dog
with a Freddy Krueger outfit on.
-Sounds like my
ex-boyfriend's grandmother.
[ Laughter ]
-Might be. It might be.
-You wouldn't lie to --
You wouldn't lie to a
pregnant woman, would you?
-I tell the truth! [ Chirps ]
-Aaah!
-I don't want to scare you.
I don't want to scare you.
I don't want to scare Baby.
I'm sorry, Baby!
I love you! I'm sorry!
Uncle Jimmy is sorry.
Uncle Jimmy loves you.
Can the baby
call me Uncle Jimmy?
-If I give birth here,
I will sue you.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna give you --
You won. You won. Cardi B,
everybody. The champion.